welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and as we brace ourselves to meet
Marvel's new big bad Kang the Conqueror
and Ant-Man that was quantum Mania Kang
actor Jonathan Majors just dropped a
major glue that connects the dots of
details Loki and Moon Knight that could
foretell how Marvel Studios might plan
to retcon all of human history as one
impacted by Kang's influence the behind
every great conqueror was a Jackman
behind the curtain which is pretty scary
not just because he's jacked but because
the Avengers defeating him would mean
undoing the very history that led to
their own existence that's kind of tough
ain't it let's break it all down also
guanamania is coming February 17th and
on that same day will be the launch of
our new channel the Deep dive which I
got something real special plan for
guanamania so please subscribe over at
Deep dive in R so Jonathan Majors just
did some press at Sundance Film Festival
in the past week and talked about his
process of creating the character of
King the Conqueror deadline shared his
response um Inspirations we came
um means conqueror right if you look at
Alexander the Great
look at the Angus Khan Julius Caesar
um
start there he's a part of a already
established universe that Universe has
um you know
yeah I mean those are those are
Inspirations and then counterpoints uh
which is also important in creating
character is to figure out
um who how to counter people you know
you're smart well watch how smart I am
you know
so you can look at um uh Robert Downey's
Iron Man and say okay if that's the
superhero of superheroes Etc and I'm
going to be a super villain of super
villains how do I counteract that in the
Zeitgeist
um
I'm not going to write a book on this at
this point whoa so much to unpack there
write a book at this
spread for a guy who's variant like to
write screenplays of everything everyone
says but he also called Iron Man the
superhero of superheroes and Kang this
super villain of super villains and the
idea of counterpoints meaning Kang and
Major's eyes is the antithesis of Tony
Stark Marvel has already implied a
connection between Kang and Iron Man
Loki concept art showing an Iron Man
helmet and he remains office and I have
speculated that Kang needed Tony Stark
to unlock the code of time travel with
his inverted Mobius strip in Avengers
end game to set history on the course to
allow Nathan Richards to later build on
that science but it's also interesting
for Majors to cite specific historical
conquerors Alexander the Great Genghis
Khan and Julius Caesar in the Loki
finale he remains hinted at this past as
a conqueror I've been dubbed many
blamed by many people
a ruler
a conqueror
he who remains
a jerk and the costume designers
deliberately designed part of he remains
wardrobe to incorporate Mongolian attire
every piece we decided was from a
different place the cape I had on was
from the Victoria era the shoes are from
Genghis Khan the the pants from Mongolia
Etc and Genghis Khan Rose to power from
the region on earth that is present-day
Mongolia in the title of Khan is
linguistically linked with the English
king as well as the Russian Czar in
Latin Caesar which all mean the same
thing ruler that is where Kang derived
its name but he specifically chose it as
a title that would be understood at any
point in human history majors using
Alexander the Great as an inspiration is
no coincidence though because both
Alexander the Great and Kang were linked
with Moon Knight and Easter eggs during
that season that have yet to be fully
explained in Moonlight episode 4 Stephen
Grant follows Arthur Heroes group to an
Egyptian tomb in search for Amit
sushanti realizing that it was inside of
a key historical figure buried there I
think we're looking
at the long lost tomb of Alexander the
Great yes it was established in MCU
cannon that Alexander the Great was
was enabled Alexander's success but
Alexander betrayed on it and helped the
inihad council imprison her in stone as
Ahmed says in episode 6 I once relied on
a servant who scales balanced perfectly
in exchange I was bound to stone for 2
000 years so while episode 4 is ending
in that Psychiatric Hospital underworld
at first suggested that much of what we
saw before it could have been a
hallucination the fact that the series
ends back in real world Egypt tells us
that Alexander the Great's MCU history
remains Canon which is insane what other
figures from our history are they gonna
say I had some kind of MCU figure
whispering in their ear remember
Alexander the Great was also a
fascination of the ten Rings all the way
back in the first Iron Man 10 Rings
operative Raza cited both Alexander the
Great and Genghis Khan in the same line
once was the Pinnacle of weapons
technology it allowed the great Genghis
Khan
the rule from the Pacific
the Ukraine
an Empire
twice the size of Alexander the Great
now going outside this time of year can
be cold wet and kind of a gross
experience enough so that I normally
think twice about running to the grocery
store but hey I've got hellofresh so I
don't got to worry about it hello fresh
is cheaper than grocery shopping and 25
cheaper than takeout it saves me that
schlep to the store with over 35 weekly
recipes hello fresh has whatever you're
looking for no matter what your diet is
you can choose calorie smart and carb
smart recipes or even customize select
Meals by swapping proteins or sides
upgrading your proteins or adding a
protein to a veggie dish you can also
stock up on snacks sides desserts and
more and hella Fresh Market just add
them to your weekly order and they'll
arrive at your doorstep along with your
meals this week I got this recipe for
like lemon chicken spaghetti meal it was
so good and so easy to make and I felt
like a real Pro lemony chicken in a
series is unfortunate yums to get
started go to hellofresh.com and use the
code rockstars21 for 21 free meals plus
free shipping once again that's
hellofresh.com and use the code
rockstars21 for 21 free meals Plus free
shipping now this latest speculation
that the ring structures we see in
quantumania footage and the Ms Marvel
Bengals origin in a cave that was marked
with the 10 Rings all point to a gang
connection with the 10 rings and now
this web of connectivity includes
Alexander the Great and Genghis Khan two
historical figures John of the majors
just cited as influences for Kang now
Marvel Studios actually intended Kang on
being very heavily woven into the Moon
Knight mythology in episode 3 The Thug's
jacket featured artwork of ferrarama Tut
one of Kang's incarnations an Easter egg
confirmed To Us by the people who worked
on the show implying that this guy was
likely the ruler or conqueror that he
remains referred to there actually was a
pharaoh Rama Tut in the MCU Egyptian
history and that guy was Kang also there
was that QR code hidden in the final
scene that took you to a free comic of
Moon Knight acts of evil from 2019 in
which Moon Knight has to fight Kang
after a long time Grudge between Kang
and konshu comes back up Moon Knight
head writer Jeremy Slater even confirmed
that he actually intended on Kang
getting mentioned in a line from the
series telling the direct there was a
line in the script and I don't know if
it survived I can't remember but there
was a line where I think Steven is sort
of rattling off some Egyptian history
that he is locked away in his brain and
he did mention Rama Tut I don't remember
if that scene if that line is still in
the show or not but it was small and it
was him mentioning a list of famous
pharaohs or something like that now of
course we did watch this show start to
finish several times and this line did
not make it into the Final Cuts but
either way this is the show's head
writer saying Kang was part of the plan
telling us that every other kangy
straight we saw was evidence of that
plan so assuming one of Kang's forms was
actually Pharaoh Rama Tut Kang could
have been connected to any famous ruler
in history his Mongolian attire could
have been his way of remembering his
time with Genghis Khan a guy who by the
way 0.5 of every human being on Earth
related to that's how busy that guy was
getting so you know he had one hell of a
wingman also by the way he was like a
major conqueror who's taking Partners at
every village he conquered and there
weren't as many people on earth back
then also the decision by Alexander the
Great to betray on it could have been
influenced by some advisor another Kang
variant to subdue the old Gods of Earth
and give him more political leverage
over the iniad forcing them into the
shadows of non-intervention clearing a
path for him to manipulate history the
reason that Moon Knight episode pointed
to that particular Kang comic could be a
clue that in the MCU in the upcoming
Avengers Kang Dynasty konshu represents
a rogue threat to Kang's control and
Moon Knight as konshu's Avatar is
uniquely protected from Kang's ability
to erase people from existence because
there's precedence in the comics that
any Avenger who has a known birth date
origin is vulnerable to Kang because
Kang knows when and where and how they
were born and thus can alter the
timeline so that they would never be
born however Heroes with unclear Origins
are harder for Kang to erase because he
wouldn't really know how they came about
and wouldn't know where air in the time
stream to create a Nexus event to block
it which brings us to an interesting
hypothetical of the altars of Mark
Spector Stephen Grant Jake lockley their
Origins are tied in with Mark's trauma
which would be harder for Kang to know
about to fully understand because those
are secrets really only known by Mark
Specter in kanchu and this might make
Moon Knight and konshu specifically the
more violent Jake lockley altar whose
origin we still don't even know Kang's
biggest blind spots yet Kang still has
the upper hand in all of this the entire
history we know has been crafted by Kang
variants a dynasty that has extended
back through human civilization since
the dawn of it which means yes there
probably was some Kang among those
Sumerians the eternals gave tools to
actually we may want to check the Domo
[__] because the 10 ranks might have
been some Celestial Tech that can swipe
from it let me know your thoughts on
these theories and a reminder to
subscribe to the Deep dive you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]